all right um over the weekend I was just
getting email after email after email
from people in the audience saying David
look here's another one of these
prominent anti-vaxxers who just died of
covid here's another one of these
prominent anti-masters who just died of
covet here's another one of these uh
Ivermectin people who just died of covid
I had three stories actually planned for
today we're only going to get to two of
them and I think these are important to
go over for a few different reasons
which we're going to get to uh the third
one we're actually going to get to
tomorrow because it's a little different
it's a militia member who was also
anti-mask and anti-vaxx who died of
covid but let's just jump right into the
first one we now have the third
conservative radio host who condemned
the covet vaccine who has died of covet
if you didn't understand what was going
on and you just zoomed out you might say
wow being a right-wing radio host seems
really dangerous in the United States in
some way this is Mark hernia he was a
Mainstay on Talk Radio in Daytona this
is the state of Florida a conservative
Florida radio host who spoke out against
covet vaccines died after a weeks-long
fight with the virus marking the third
radio personality to die from
coronavirus who publicly rejected
vaccines the death of Mark Bernier 65
who was a Mainstay on Talk Radio in
Daytona was announced Saturday night by
the radio station wndb that he was
affiliated with for three decades it is
with great sadness that wndb and the
southern Stone Communications announced
the passing of Mark Bernier who informed
and entertained listeners on wndb for
over 30 years we kindly ask that privacy
is given to Mark's family during this
time of this time of grief
I think that there it would be more
useful if they didn't hide the cause of
death in these announcements this is an
it's almost exactly like the Phil
Valentine thing where the radio station
statement doesn't mention the anti-vax
element and the covet death even if it's
not you don't have to attack the person
but just say of covet folks let's send
this together get the vaccine wear a
mask where recommended there would
actually be some more that comes from
this that would be useful
um Bernier was known for inviting
different viewpoints on the show
including Democrats but had publicly
railed against vaccines the Daytona
Beach News Journal reported Bernier had
been hospitalized since August 7.
when Florida's Democratic agriculture
commissioner Nikki fried in July urged
people to get vaccines on Twitter by
saying the greatest Generation had to
defeat the Nazis to preserve our way of
life you're only asked being asked to
get a shot so be a patriot Bernier
replied on the platform should say now
the U.S government is acting like Nazis
get the shot
died of covid
likened the vaccine
to vac to Nazism
dead of covet okay
freed is challenging Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis in 22 said my heart goes
out to his family and friends we covered
this story previously on August 4th
another Florida conservative radio hosts
who had criticized the coronavirus
vaccine dick Farrell also died from
covid complications uh Farrell had
worked at several radio stations and was
a fill-in anchor on Newsmax he strongly
condemned the vaccine posting on July
3rd why take a vaccine promoted by
people who lied to you all along about
masks where the virus came from and the
death toll of course there were no lies
about masks in March of 2020 Dr fauci
said it's probably not necessary for the
general population by April of 2020
fauci and everyone else was saying we
now know more wear the mask
lied about where the virus came from
that's just lab leak hypothesis stuff
that's unproven and lied about the death
toll it's actually been the State of
Florida that has been
um uh playing fast and loose with the
statistics and actually that but I I've
mentioned this before but let me just
slightly digress over the weekend I got
a bunch of emails from people saying
David why do Florida's death numbers
look so good
anytime you look at Florida's death
count it's low it's it's just collapsed
this is a game Florida is playing and I
told you about it a week and a half ago
what Florida is doing is they are
reporting coveted deaths a full week at
a time for the previous week the way
most of these websites work is if
Florida doesn't report cases for
yesterday it shows up as a zero if
Florida doesn't show report cases deaths
for the day before it shows as zero so
what Florida is constantly doing is
saying okay it's now August 30th
here's the death numbers for August 22nd
23rd 24th and 25th and those go crazy
but then because they've not reported
the recent dates it crashes to almost
zero and then next week they'll report
the numbers for this week the point is
Florida is playing a game whereby
delaying reporting by a week and doing a
week at a time it always looks like the
last five to seven days are just looking
really good in Florida it's just a game
you have to understand that that's
what's going on and now two right-wing
Florida radio hosts plus Phil Valentine
from uh
was it Georgia Tennessee I think
Tennessee
multiple anti-vaxx right-wing radio
hosts have now died of covid let's go on
to the next similar story